what does a declining birth rate mean in
terms of both Countrywide and Global GDP
it's not good there's nothing good about
it I think people imagine and it's
understandable that you think we can
slowly slide our populations down slide
our economies down so we all just shrink
a little bit you know year by year that
it's almost going to be like an airplane
kind of slowly coming into land and
we'll have this kind of resettling it's
not like that people say there was only
two billion people on the planet a
hundred years ago why is it a problem
that we would go back to that the
transition is a problem one other factor
is that we have no example of a country
that went through this and came out the
other side unless it was a period of
famine or war that went down with such a
low birth rate as we're seeing now and
then rebalance itself no it's like
civilization in history has ever
recovered from this type of population
collapse that's what you're saying
that's exactly what I'm saying